بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
والصلاه والسلام السلام على رسوله الكريم
‏to fancy
to fancy.
[Silence]
‏Try it now.
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
[Silence]
اما بعد
الوجيز في فقه السنه والكتاب العزيز
تيرجسه
[Silence]
يقول المؤلف تطهير ذيل ثوب
ان شاء الله يقول عن ام ولد لابراهيم بن
عبد الرحمن بن عوف
[Silence]
يقول عن ام ولد
لابراهيم بن عبد الرحمن بن عوف انها سالت
ام سلمه زوج النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
فقالت
اني امراه اطيل ذيلي وامشي في المكان
القدر
فقالت ام سلمه قال النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم يطهره
ما بعده
والحديث
اخرجه ابو داوود والترمذي وابن ماجه في
سننهم واخرجه الطيالسي
في مسنده
‏So we have here narration that one of
the
mothers
of
children
came to the prophet's wife صلى الله
عليه وسلم and asked her say
I to keep the tail to my dress long
and
sometimes I
‏ing and I pass through unsan unclean
part
in the
meaning that this
could poss
you know find on the ta of her asing
and ام سلمه رضي الله عنها
صلى الله عليه وسلم
يطهره
ما بعده
un
now
this com
يقول تطهير ذيل المراه
تطهير ذيل ثوب المراه
وهذا
الوصف هو وصف فعال بمعنى ان هذا لا يكون
لذيل ثوب الرجل
يؤاخذ
بما يحمله
ا ذيل ثوبه
لانه لا يجوز له ان يجتر ثوبه
و
هذا
يختص بالمراه المراه هي التي لها مصلحه
ستر عورتها
وستر قدميه يها ولذلك
عفى الشارع عن ما يلقاه ذيل ثوب المراه من
ال
المستقذر من الارض وقال يطهره ما بعده من
الارض اما الرجل فقال النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم
ازره المؤمن الى نصف الساق
فان كان لا بد فالى الكعبين
وما دون الكعبين من الازار ففي النار هكذا
قال صلى الله عليه وسلم so here we have
the description of the he says this
narration ising specifically
the cleanliness
of the tail of a woman's dress now
norally
صلى الله عليه وسلم
النساء شقائق الرجال
‏comm
this all things rule
specifically the of the dr
of theem the purose for that
is to conceal her feet because a woman's
feet is considered to be عوره
مذاهب
مذهب ابي حنيفه
ومالك والشافعي واحمد
عوره
ابو حنيفه رحمه اللههلا
[Silence]
انصلاه
ابو حنيفه رحمه الله
عوره
[Silence]
ابي حنيفه رحمه
ابو حنيفه
[Silence]
ابي حنيفه رحمه
طوافوا
طواف كetب
[Silence]
سوره النور الله سبحانه وتعالى
ولا يضربن
ايش بارجلهن
ليعلم
ما يخفين
من زينتهن
وذكر هنا ليعلم
وهذا اشد من ليرى
فلو كان في اي في الرجل مثلا خلخال وله
صوت فيقول الله ولا يضربن بارجلهن
ليعلم
ما يخفين من زينتهن
لكن ليرى ما يخفين من زينتهن هذا من باب
اولى
ولذلك ذلك اجمع الفقهاء على ان قدم المراه
عوره
ولا بد ان تحتجب وانما اختلفوا في مساله
الصلاه المراه تصلي وحدها في بيتها حيث لا
يراها احد من الرجال
هل يجوز لها ان تبدي قدميها في الصلاه ام
من عوره الصلاه ان تستر قدم جمعيها خلاف
بين الفقهاء
والذي قال به مالك والشافعي واحمد رحمهم
الله ان قدم المراه في الصلاه عوره وانما
اختلف ابو حنيفه رحمه الله مع اخوانه
الفقهاء واصحاب المذاهب في هذه المساله
الله سبحانه وتعالى سوره النور
‏theirause
to know what they are concealing of
beautification and adornment and what
meant here by that is that for instance
a woman may have ankl or some kind of
jewel on her feet and that if she were
to move her feet in a specific way would
make a noise it would make a very
particular ‏of
associated
with a associated with adornment and
beautification is associated and so
pribit that moving a way that would
cause a listener to know what is
concealed
notice the wording a listener to know
how much more so
هذا من باب اولى
صلى الله عليه
‏to the midle of the midle of
so the women said
for the wom
he said one
hand
below that
so if the would have their to
اذا
ترى اقدامه
ولا يزدن على
‏in
concealing feet now we will have some
fall because of that why is that because
will ta as walks it may collect things
right it may come across a ground that
is impure and these impurities may make
their way into the tail of her dress
صلى الله عليه وسلم
يطهره
ما
[Silence]
‏Now we said the second principle of
that all areased
the first princileuse me that we
mentioned which
‏if take
and smell it for instance would a person
be able to detect impurity some kind of
perhaps or may even correct but she is
not commanded to what to wash that and
that because that's unnecessary
‏to
kind
of so for the of the of this is
this
no if
‏becauseoues
toow
[Silence]
كما يقول عمر
فهو اطهر لثوبك واتقى لربك نسال الله
سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده ان يعلمنا
ما ينفعنا وان ينفعنا بما علمنا بما علمنا
وان يفقهنا في ديننا وان يزيدنا والله
اعلم والله وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا